In the US, a sharply divided US electorate...
...is voting in midterm elections.
All 435 seats in the House of Representatives are at stake,...
...plus 35 of the 100 US Senate seats...
...and 36 of the 50 state governorships.
In Spain, rescue workers continue to search...
...for 17 more missing migrants...
...after finding the bodies of 17 others...
...who died trying to cross the Mediterranean from Africa in boats.
The United Nations said that in Iraq, more than 200 mass graves...
...believed to contain the remains of thousands of victims...
...of Islamic State violence have been found.
NATO Secretary General Jens Stoltenberg says...
...it is in the interest of the alliance to remain in Afghanistan...
...to increase its security as well as that of Afghanistan.
Finally from France, at least eight people are feared dead...
...after two apartment buildings collapsed suddenly in Marseille.
Three bodies have been pulled from the wreckage.